JLo's rom-com return hits theaters
tomorrow and if that wasn't reason
enough to get you to the theater how
about I add in Milo Ventimiglia ask
expand those genes by the way again
I'm not a piece of meat Jennifer Lopez
hand picks you for this Jennifer wanted
to hop in the shower with you Jeff
wanted to comment on your backside
Jennifer wanted to break up with you it
was really cute yeah yeah we kind of
work you seriously I've dropped the hint
before and I'm just gonna do it again
JLo we need you on this is us I don't
know if we need to do that to the jacket
Rebecca dynamic or anything I think what
we probably should do is just Jennifer
and I should speak okay
did this once it works let's just do it
again
mm-hmm third act but being J Lo's man on
screen was harder than it looks
here's why while we were doing this
movie that was the same time I was
filming the Pearson home burning down
yeah so I mean I was in that headspace
in Los Angeles then I have to go to New
York and break up with Jennifer you know
play that no fun but then you know at
least like you know we shower together
by the end of the production schedule
yeah it was good
[Music]